[Music]
thank you
last year in February 24
as everybody knows Russian forces
invaded Ukraine in Vienna during our
last ftth conference we gave the floor
to leaders of Ukraine Telecom industry
and I can see our speaker of last year's
sitting front row Mr nabok
um
the ftth council's clearly
reaffirms its support for Ukraine and
with that in mind I would like to
introduce you to our next speaker
Yuri matsik he is head of fixed
Broadband in Ukraine's Ministry of
digital transformation please welcome
Yuri maxi
[Applause]
thank you incense
I'm honored to be here to represent
Ukraine and share some ideas with you
I live in Kiev Ukraine the capital of
the bravest people who defend our
freedom
I
thank you
I would like uh to hear some questions
for audience if you don't mind sure
please raise your hands those you who
was in ukrainians last year and saw the
destroy infrastructure raise your hand
please
one two
thank you you're as Brave as ukrainians
well thank you irie I guess my first
question to you would be that before
February 24th what was the situation in
Ukraine regarding ftth rollout what
where you plan
prior War
first of all before the 20 February 2022
we set up some goals for four strategic
goals of ukrainians
uh to converse to a 100 percent of
strategic uh to Public Services Center
Online to cover 95 percent of population
and social facility with high-speed
internet access
and to teach 6 million people with basic
digital skills and to grow the share of
I.T
the counties of GDP from four to ten
percent
um
so until 20 February 4 everything was
clear and defined and we were about to
achieve them
90 percent of citizens got the
opportunity to use high-speed internet
and over 1 million citizens will which
leave in the citizens and Villages have
got their high-speed internet firstly
one million people and three Thousand
Villages and three million people who
live in 8
000 towns got excess 4G firstly
and then Russia in way to Ukraine yeah
and so what how's the situation has
evolved practically since uh since
February 22. as you know the last 14
months uh the rocky there are has been a
full-scale war in Ukraine uh charging
the smartphone or tablet and connection
in Internet turn out to be more
important
after all there is nothing more
important than stay in touch with your
family
according to World Bank two billion
dollars losses of the Telecom sectors
25 percent of the internet networks in
the country were destroyed
90 operators are in the virtue of
bankruptcy over a thousand cyber attacks
were reported targeting I.T and
Telecommunications more than thousands
people who died in Ukraine
I guess we have got
more familiar with the situation in
Ukraine of course and I guess
how critical you mentioned the The
Importance of Being connected and
staying in touch with family but how
critical is the Telecom infrastructure
also for military operation and and
Ukrainian Army
um this world change view of the
battlefield
if you see if you use the drones
uh you have a local advantage in the
front
if you are connecting to run with uh
response of all military uh with all
military points which make a decision in
the front you have Advantage at the
front
and we have advantages at the war
and in this link in the chain we need to
make a resilient internet connection
between all of the military points who
have solver
who have a problem on the battlefield
besides all military points they use
internet connection operates a military
divisions that's why stable internet
access must be reliable and safe and
protected
uh we need to grow much more safety
connections between countries and get
rid on depends on the enemy not only
guess
electricity
but internet too
and you know beyond that what about the
situation of civil infrastructure
can the countries kind of operate
normally somehow what's the situation
how is it felt by population at large
last year we had survived three
different biggest challenges
firstly many Big Bone lines were
destroyed one times in a lot of places
and even if users live far from the
front
they had had problems with internet
access
second some the mobile towers and
networks after in region were rebuilt
temporarily
and third enemies have destroys
electricity Networks and the Ukrainian
Telecom networks wasn't ready to
overcome this problem
my Vortex worst experience without
electricity at 72 hours in row
during scheduled outage four hours by
four hours without electricity 70
percent of fixed operator Services
didn't work
only passive Optical Network can be more
effective against the situation
and I guess you you constantly need to
look at repairing maintaining the
network so how do you practically manage
this technically any any specific
technology have to be leveraged
when all bio operator experience a
problem with destroy a base station the
United and set up internal roaming
it means when one operator lost the
station customer can call using a
network in other mobile operators
besides mobile operators got new
frequencies without pay from government
government cancel pay for electricity
can spell for electricity pillars and
the start of the full-scale war we
operators don't stop services for
customers who couldn't pay
um government telecomparations and
private company got donations for the
recovery and for the network fix the
mobile internet access has been
partially restored
this is a long-end experience recovery
process
finally we use Sterling
some operators use their link from
link for the village
if some clients have fixed Network we
can use
internet access at home
and butcher
which I became the first city which was
effective affected the brutal enemy
there was nothing left in the city after
the invasion
uh but one Tower switch on the generator
and Sterling
people come to this place charging
smartphone
and they can call to family and read the
news
it's very very important for us
today we was about to 42
000 Sterling in Ukraine
and moving to a different subject what
are the type of support you're receiving
from your European countries and for the
from the EU institutions uh in in these
circumstances uh most Sterling terminals
we uh received from the government of
Poland nearly 50 000
from government of Germany and uh 10 000
from uh initiative of Europe Union
countries ministries of digitalizations
5000 and from you see it and private
company and private persons in other
Australians
um
some of some government international
government companies
and not uh
[Music]
for example ing ing is our supported
they started a project at keep Ukraine
connected
digital yo for digital Ukraine uh
and private company who can support in
Ukraine and make it
uh in one moment
is something
undp I'm sorry UDP and Theft 2.
today Ukraine is candidate for the
Europe Union and we strive to connect
with internal uh digital market
and uh
and we integrate in EU
and we think about a far far from it
very thank you and maybe as a conclusion
last question
um you know what what additional support
would you need what would be your
request for for the audience today
unfortunately what what do you expect
for your industry and your organization
uh today we need recovery to
telecommunication infrastructure after
the Innovation and to make all parts of
the internet networks much more
resilient safe and to make all and
protected including the international
backbone
next we realize the problem with our
operators
first first it's human capital
Ukrainian operators
have decreased
off number employees
part of them go to went to the Army and
some women with their children go to
abroad
second cash flow
now also at the occupation territory is
a lot of people leave their homes
who stay and lives they can't pay for
services
it means the internet operators don't
have enough cash flow
and they need
restore infrastructure and new build new
lines after the invasion
and to the government began the pilot
project of construction of some cities
I have Nokia want to start the pilot
project in Ukraine you're welcome
uh you need the platform uh for
operators which had destroyed her
network with donors we as a company at
any home
uh to be our promoter
and what more important
foundation for recovery
we are also seeking funding for
projects to restore
the Telecommunications here in Ukraine
and European Union should find a better
solution for all of us
and one moment I want to draw your more
attention
if you
or your friend
your company or your partners
think about
how to make this world better
you have the biggest opportunity to take
one Village
or one region in Ukraine and fulfill
your bravest Minds about reconstruction
Ukraine
it will contribute to your company a lot
and today Ukraine is a
best
testing ground for any innovative
solutions
and those companies which have been able
to harness opportunity during their time
well definitely have a competitive
Advantage among others
for example
the week starlink were showcased
we in Ukraine have unique skills about
making Fast Solutions
and for solving great problems
and
in particular supports internet access
Ukraine has begun to create Trends in
utilization and you can join it
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you